do you guys know what fomo is
[Music]
perfect i really only get fomo
about what other people order at a
restaurant i do my friends call me the
seagull i'm like
i really do i just i always want to eat
what everybody else has but a recent
study
from psychological reports found a
direct link between the
time spent on instagram and fomo i mean
that makes
perfect sense and there's a whole new
generation you know that's really kind
of
dealing and grappling with the emotional
toll of that
so what can we do about it my next guest
is here to tell us about the concept of
jomo or yeah the joy
of missing out which i think i can get
into because i'm a total shut-in
please welcome author podcaster and
purpose coat
the great j
you oh my shetty i totally have to admit
i watch you
all the time on all these other shows
that i can't believe you're actually on
this one this
is so exciting i'm grateful to be here
i'm so grateful and excited thanks for
having me
well thank you for being on the show and
will you please tell us
what jomo is yeah so drew as you
mentioned
jomo is a well-known as the joy of
missing out
and psychologists and coaches see this
as a powerful mindset
that helps us find peace and connection
in our own lives
as opposed to feeling the anxiety and
pressure that we should
be somewhere else or be doing something
else
i mean you have a concept called time
right will you explain that to me i know
what it stands for but will you please
tell
everybody yes so if we want to
experience the joy of missing out there
are
four daily practices that each and every
one of us can do
and it comes in the form of the acronym
time so t i
m e the t stands for thankfulness
not just feeling thanks not just
experiencing it but expressing it
finding
one person a day to say thanks to makes
us realize the joy that we already have
in our lives
the second thing is i for inspiration
if you're learning every day whether
it's about a new city whether it's about
new food or whether it's a new word
when you feel you're learning and
growing you start to feel inspiration
and you don't look for the validation of
others as much the third one is of
course
m and that stands for meditation now i
know meditation can be quite daunting
and difficult
but it's as simple as finding one thing
that you can do with yourself every day
it could be tea it could be reading your
favorite book just finding some time
to spend with yourself and the fourth
one is exercise
now this doesn't just mean treadmills
and gyms it can be a dance party
it can be moving outdoors it can be your
favorite sport
but if you can make time every day for
thankfulness inspiration
meditation and exercise you'll
experience the joy
of your own company and being in a space
of calm with yourself so when i talked
to
our news crew this morning about the
time concept that you have i thought i
am a thankful person i'm gonna have like
death by inspo because it's just coming
out of every orifice i mean really it's
like it's too much already sometimes
it's gonna say it on my head's phone
headstone like death by inspo because
i'm just like i love everything
and um exercise i'm on it um
the meditation part is something that i
wish that i could really bring to my
life
and the way you just spoke about it made
me feel like
maybe i should be a little less hard on
myself which is like a whole other
subject we need like
an entire empowered yeah no like we need
the empower hour with jay shetty because
i need to
you know i'm working on that but
meditation is something that i think
really intimidates people i think we
think if we're not getting really quiet
and carving out this time which a lot of
us cannot find
even five minutes especially as parents
and working and all of that
you mentioned that reading a book or
doing an action like making yourself a
tea
can that be a form of meditation
absolutely it's just about being really
present with whatever activity or habit
you're doing
so smell the tea breathe it in
listen to it as you stir it really sip
it and feel every flavor
it's a great way of practicing presents
well i think that's a great way also to
show people that they can bring it into
their lives acknowledge the moment and
not feel bad that they're not going away
for 20 minutes and like
going out into the ether exactly
is there anything silly for jomo like
you know
goofy times i i i had this confession
drew that i want to share with you
because this definitely gets me through
sometimes
i i love soccer and basketball
video games so that's something that i
will miss out on anything for if i can
get away with a couple of games
of soccer or basketball on my
playstation
so the key is find your jomo
[Music]